Кілька людей біля пам'ятника Твардовського у Москві оголосили безстрокову акцію протесту.
Це продовження мітингів проти пенсійної реформи, що відбулися напередодні.
Тут вони провели всю ніч.
Ми ніби стихійно сюди вийшли. Якби ми заздалегідь знали, ми б тепліше одяглися.
Так, загалом, не дуже було тепло. Ми свічки тут поставили і грілися.
Приходили 2-3 людини, приносили теплі речі.
Відео жорстоких розгонів Владислава Попова не дивує.
Все як завжди.
У Петербурзі видно, що людей сильно пресують.
У Москві тільки одне зіткнення було дуже жорстке,
але там дійсно били кийками прямо маленьких дівчат.
У Москві зіткнення з поліцією сталися після того, як учасники протестної акції вирушили до Кремля.
Кількох активістів повалили на землю, їх били кийками і відводили в автозаки.
У відповідь у поліцейських кидали пляшки.
А починалося все мирно - сюди в неділю прийшли кілька тисяч людей.
Поліцейські невтомно нагадували, що акція несанкціонована.
Шановні громадяни, прохання розійтися і не заважати пересуванню інших громадян,
оскільки ви берете участь у несанкціонованій акції.
Учасники мітингу вимагали відставки уряду, звільнення політв'язнів,
а також скасування пенсійної реформи.
У мене троє онуків. Я би через 5 років уже сиділа б з онуками.
Натомість дітки будуть сидіти і не працювати.
А я буду пахати. А потім відразу, напевно, на кладовище.
Бідні пенсіонери вже скоро вимруть усі, тому що бідно живуть.
І нічого для цього не робиться. Постійна брехня якась.
Турбуюся за своє майбутнє і за свою тітку.
Вона вийде на пенсію на 5 років пізніше.
І так важко працювати в Росії, і так грошей немає, а ще вона просто не доживе до цієї пенсії.
Після затримань мітинг почав згасати, площу перегородили подвійним парканом.
До ранку понеділка мітингувальників залишилося лише семеро.
Періодично до них приходили співробітники поліції.
Години до 12-тої омонівців десь приблизно 15 підходило.
Опа, до нас ще йдуть. Я не знаю, мені можна продовжувати зараз говорити?
Цих активістів також затримали. Утім протестний настрій ще не вщухає.
Всього у Росії затримали понад тисячу протестувальників, найбільше - у Санкт-Петербурзі.